Schönen guten Abend. Mein Name ist Bulur. Heute bin ich der Dienstabendarzt auf dieser Station.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmengespräch dürfen.
Bevor wir über Ihren aktuellen Beschwerdensprächen, brauche ich ein paar Informationen über Ihre personenikannten.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Margret Handorf.
Ich heiße dann Margret.
Wie heißen Sie Frau Handorf?
Ich bin 50 Jahre alt.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,78 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
83 kg.
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen, wenn Sie Beschwerden haben, die Akte?
Ich habe solche unglaublichen Bauchschmerzen.
Das kommt immer in so Wellen.
Mir ist auch deutlich schlecht.
Da kramft sich der ganze Bauch zusammen.
Mir ist wirklich schlecht.
Ich mag auch überhaupt nichts essen.
Ich musste mich auch übergeben.
Ich fühle mich total schlecht.
Ich habe mich extrem schlecht gefühlt.
Ich habe auch Temperatur gemessen.
Das war auch bei 38 kg.
Das kenne ich eigentlich gar nicht.
Man fiebert schon mal.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerde?
Das ging gestern Abend.
Nach dem Abendessen habe ich mich heute über den Tag gequält.
Aber genau genommen war mit mir heute gar nichts mehr los.
Haben Sie Bauchschmerzen?
Ja, immer diese Krämpfe im Oberbauch.
Ganz heftig.
Wie stark sind Sie?
Ja, wir sind sehr stark.
Wir haben hier schon eine starke Schmerz.
Ja, es ist schon sehr heftig.
Wie ist die Skala?
Die Skala ist sehr leicht.
Wir sind sehr stark.
Aber ich denke, Sie haben schon eine starke Schmerz.
Also bei acht sind die bestimmt, bei acht von zehn sind die bestimmt die Schmerzen.
Ja, soll ich Ihnen ein Schmerzmittel geben?
Ja, wenn Sie mir etwas geben können, was so ein bisschen mir jetzt leichterung gibt, das wäre schon gut, ja.
Ja, okay. Und wie gegen das Gespräch, die richtige Richtung.
Okay. Und Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Schmerzen obviel waren und strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus.
Ja, also das strahlt sogar bis in den Rücken rein und ich habe auch das Gefühl, so ein bisschen in die rechte Schulter.
Ja, Frau Handorf, das ist eine Unfallstituation, ich denke.
Ich hatte keinen Unfall, nein.
Ja, ich werde in einer Notfallstituation ihre Viteilparameter kontrollieren und eine EKG schreiben.
Beinen Sie, dass ich etwas am Herzen habe?
Ja, ich möchte sicher sein. Jetzt werde ich bei Ihnen eine EKG schreiben.
Okay, gut.
Jetzt machen wir weiter, ne?
Ja, okay, danke schön.
Ja, und gibt es bestimmte Auslöse für die Schmerzen? Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie nicht essen?
Ja, also gestern Abend haben wir uns auch so deftige Bratkartoffeln gemacht mit viel Speck und das habe ich gar nicht vertragen.
Und danach fing das richtig schlimm an und ich meine, ich habe das schon seit längerer Zeit, dass ich so ein bisschen aufpassen muss mit fettigem Essen,
aber das hat mich jetzt so geschafft, also bei Schlagsahne und so, das habe ich eigentlich schon immer weggelassen.
Ja, das war gestern Abend, war der Tatar so gut, was heißes zu essen nach dem kalten Tag und wir waren viel draußen und dann, ja,
und danach musste ich aber richtig grüßen, da hat es richtig wiegegangen.
Ich denke, damit hat es angefangen.
Ja, und gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Ja, also ich habe das Gefühl, dass es, wenn ich mich so gerade übergeben hatte, dass es danach dann wieder ein bisschen besser war,
aber das war immer nur einen kurzen Augenblick, dann ging das eigentlich sofort wieder los.
Ja, okay. Und verstärkt, gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen verstärkt?
Ja, ich habe mich eigentlich ja jetzt heute den ganzen Tag nur so rumgequält, ich konnte nicht viel rumlaufen oder so, das hat immer viel zu sehr weh getan.
Ja, also ich habe mehr oder weniger heute nur rumgelegen oder gesessen und war immer froh, wenn ich in der Nähe hatte, wenn ich mich übergeben musste.
Okay.
Sind die Schmerzen in der Lache Schlima geworden oder BSA geworden?
BSA sind sie nicht geworden, ich würde sagen.
Ich denke, Schlima.
Das ist immer gleich.
Okay, verstehe. Und sind die Schmerzen plötzlich aufgetreten?
Ja, das ging mit einmal los, ja.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben Fieber und 39 Grad und wann haben Sie Ihre Körpertemperatur gemessen? Gestern oder?
Ne, heute Morgen habe ich das, weil es nicht so schlecht ging.
Okay, in Oral gemessen oder Achselhöhe?
Achselhöhe.
Haben Sie Nachschweiß?
Nein, eigentlich kenne ich das nicht. Nein.
Okay.
Und ist Ihnen übel?
Ja, übel ist mir weiß Gott, das sagt ich ja schon.
Ja.
Und Sie 3-4 Mal erbrücken?
Ja, ich kann gar nicht so genau mitgesagt, weil ich musste mich immer wieder übergeben.
Wie sieht das Erbrechene aus?
Ja, das ist so gelbe Zeug, das man gegessen und getrunken hat.
Aber ich meine auch tatsächlich, ich habe keine Tomaten gegessen, da war irgendetwas Rotes drin.
Das kann also sein, dass da irgendwie auch so ein bisschen Blut dabei war.
Okay, verstehe.
Ja, das ist frische Blut, ja, rötte Blut oder als eine Kaffeersatz?
Ne, sie kaffeersatz sieht es nicht aus. Nein.
Okay.
Und sind Sontbirennen, Sauerausstoß oder Bilehungen bei Ihnen aufgefallen?
Ne, eigentlich nicht.
Also das habe ich alles eigentlich so normalerweise nicht.
Ja, also wie gesagt, wenn ich jetzt fettiges Essen gegessen habe in den Wochen davor,
ja, da hatte ich schon mal so ein bisschen Druckgefühle oder auch mal so drin,
aber jetzt nicht besonders doll.
Okay, verstehe.
Und haben Sie Atemnot, Herzrasen?
Nein, nein, so habe ich nicht.
Husten? Husten habe ich auch nicht.
Vorher haben Sie für diese ähnliche Beschwerden früher?
Ja, ich sagte ja, dass ich bei fettiges Essen jetzt in letzter Zeit eben schon mal so ein bisschen Bauchdrücken hatte,
aber dass das jetzt so schlimm ist wie jetzt, das war noch nie so.
Und ja, Ihre Beschwerde sind gestern auftreten.
Ja, nach dem Abendessen, ja, wenn eine Weile sich dann sagen, oh, dann ging es aber los.
Ich meine, waren Sie für diese Beschwerde hausarst?
Nein, nein, nein.
Okay, und haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder mit dem Stuhlgang?
Na ja, also, ich meine, ich muss halt lachen, irgendwie so einmal wenigstens auch die Toilette,
aber also das habe ich schon lange, ja.
Ja, und Sie haben Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Ja, eben nur, dass ich Nachts extra raus muss.
Entschuldigung, ich habe nicht gut verstehen.
Verstanden, ich muss einmal in der Nacht auf die Toilette, das ist also mein Problem mit dem Wasserlassen.
Und was mir aufgefallen ist, dass der Urin, dass der so ein bisschen anders aussah als sonst,
ja, irgendwie viel dunkler, sonst ist es ja immer so hell gelb.
Jetzt war das sogar ein bisschen dunkel, das habe ich gesehen.
Ja, und haben Sie Schmerzen beim Urin?
Nein, nein, also beim Wasserlassen habe ich keine Schmerzen, nein.
Ja, okay.
Ja, sind bei Ihnen ja Verfarbung in Schutul, Ihre Schutul bemerkt?
Das habe ich nicht, habe ich nicht so bemerkt.
Ja, okay.
Und Ihr Schutul ist normalbereich und Farbe oder?
Ja, ich meine, das sieht normal aus, ja, das ist halt ja immer, was man so gegessen hat, immer.
Okay, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, eigentlich bin ich immer stabil.
Okay, und waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Oh nein, wissen Sie, wir haben landwirtschaftlichen Betrieb, da kann man sich keine großen Reisen erlauben,
da kann man nicht lange wegnehmen, ich war die ganze Zeit zu Hause.
Und sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Geimpft, naja, was man so hat nicht, also Grippe und natürlich Corona, ja, da bin ich geimpft, ja.
Ja, als Kinderkrankheit auch, ja.
Ja, als Kind bin ich natürlich gegen Kinderkrankheiten geimpft worden, ja, natürlich.
Treiben Sie Sport regelmäßig für eine Hand?
Ja, also ich habe sehr anstrengende körperliche Arbeit, deswegen mache ich eigentlich wenig Sport,
aber manchmal fahre ich, also ich fahre viel mit dem Fahrrad, wenn ich unterwegs bin.
Und ansonsten mache ich manchmal, wenn ich dazu komme, ein bisschen Gymnastik ums zu bleiben,
aber überwiegend habe ich eben viel körperliche Arbeit.
Ja, ich denke, Sie treiben regelmäßig Sport.
Und ja, ich möchte fragen, Herr Hangdorf,
haben Sie für diese Beschwerden Bauchsmärzen zu Hause etwas genommen, ein Medikament?
Nein, ich habe nur ein bisschen Chamillenthe getrunken und ja, halt ja so das übliche Zwieback gegessen,
aber dass ich jetzt irgendwie Medizin genommen habe, nein, das habe ich nicht.
Okay, und haben Sie irgendwelche Kuronische vor Erkrankungen?
Ja, was man so hat in meinem Alter nicht mehr, Blutdruck ist ein bisschen hoch, ne?
Ja, seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Ja, das ist so seit fünf, sechs Jahren so etwas, ja.
Und 15 Jahre?
5 bis, ne, 5, 6 Jahre.
Okay, ich weiß es nicht genau.
Und noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Ja, also, was bekannt ist bei mir, ich habe einen grünen Starr auf beiden Augen
und da muss ich halt regelmäßig Augenthorpe nehmen, ne?
Kennen Sie, ja, wissen Sie der Name des Medikaments?
Das kann ich Ihnen gar nicht sagen, wie die heißen, das weiß ich gar nicht.
Oder doch, doch, warten Sie, das hat einen witzigen Namen, das heißt Timohexal.
Timohexal.
Und da muss ich morgens und abends in jedes Auge eintropfen und damit ist es okay.
Okay, jedes Auge.
Und seit wann haben Sie Grünöschter?
Ja, vor acht Jahren hat man das festgestellt.
Okay.
Und noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Also ich habe natürlich zu tun ein bisschen mit dem Rücken, weil die Arbeit so anstrengend ist,
dann habe ich immer mal so Rhythmschmerzen, aber sonst eigentlich nix.
Ja, haben Sie beim Scheibenvorfall oder?
Nein, das ist einfach nur ein bisschen über anstrengend, denke ich.
Sie müssen halt schon viel schwerheben und viel körperlich arbeiten.
Sie haben seit sechs Jahren Grünöschter, nicht Grauöschter.
Ja.
Ja, okay.
Und wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, als Kind habe ich mal eine Blindarmoperation gehabt.
Und dann hatte ich vor, da ist schon lange her, bestimmt so 15 Jahre,
da hatte ich einen Arbeitsunfall, da habe ich mir das linke Handgelenk gebrochen.
Und das ist versorgt worden mit Platten und Schrauben
und da mussten die das Metall dann nachher wieder raus.
Ja, Metallpillagrat implantieren.
Metallpillagrat, ja.
Und war das Operation komplikationlos?
Die Operation, ja, also ich habe halt Schmerzen gehabt, aber das gehört wohl dazu.
Okay, klar.
Und nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikament an, ein?
Ja, also einmal diese Augen treffen und dann nehme ich eben noch ein Medikament gegen den Blutdruck.
Dann nehme ich B-Lock 95.
Einmal?
Dann nehme ich mich nur eine morgens, ja.
Okay, noch andere Medikamente?
Nee, sonst nehme ich eigentlich nix.
Haben Sie allergen oder Unverträglichkeit?
Ja, also allergisch bin ich da wirklich auch viele Sachen.
Und zwar, ja, das fängt jetzt im Frühling wieder an auf Birkenpollen.
Ja, wenn die Birken blühen, dann habe ich, und bei Hausstaub habe ich das auch,
dass ich Augen trenn habe und Schnupfen und so.
Und ja, man sagt eben auch heuch-chnupfen dazu, ne?
Und ich darf keine Haselnüsse essen, da bekomme ich auch eine Allergie.
Und dann hat man eben auch festgestellt, dass ich auf Penicillin und auf Tetracycline allergisch bin.
Ich habe auch so ein Allergiepass.
Und da steht auch drin, dass ich auch zusätzlich noch so eine Jodallergie habe.
Das darf ich auch nicht bekommen.
Sie sind allergisch, ja?
Ja, ja, ja.
Und ich möchte ein paar Fragen über Nuxen.
Rauchen Sie, Frau Handorf?
Nee, nee, nee, rauchen Sie nicht.
Ja, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, das gehört so ein bisschen dazu bei uns, ja.
Ich trink also regelmäßig ein paar Gläserweine am Abend so, ne?
Wie viel trinken Sie?
Ja, also 2,4, 3, 2,4 sind das bestimmt immer, ja.
2,4 Flasche, ja?
Also 2,4 Liter, ne?
2,4 Liter.
Also nur so 4 Liter Gläser, da trinke ich schon 2 Stück, ja.
Ja, Sie meinen 2,4 Liter ungefähr, so weit?
1,5 Liter am Tag, ja.
Aber immer nur so, um sein Haus zu weinen, also ein leichter weißes Wein.
Nichts Schlimmes.
Und das ist Routinefrage, Frau Handorf, nehmen Sie Droge?
Nein, das kann ich nur wirklich nicht, nein.
Okay, und sind in Ihrer Familie irgendwelche Kuronsche
vor Erkrankungen bekannt?
Ja, also meine Mutter leidet an einer heftigen Demenz
und ist also entsprechend pflegebedürftig, das macht uns auch natürlich viel Arbeit.
Und mein Vater ist gestorben, einem Herzinfarkt, der ist gar nicht alt geworden,
der ist nur 70 Jahre alt geworden.
Was war das?
Ja, das ist jetzt schon ein paar Jahre her.
Ja, ist doch 5, 6 Jahre.
So 5, 6 Jahre her, ist ja gestorben.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ein Bruder habe ich ja.
Ist er gesund?
Oh, nee, der hat eine kranke Leber, ja.
Ja, danke, danke.
Wie wurden er behandelt?
Ja, ich glaube, er kriegt Medikamente und ja, aber also,
dem geht es nicht so gut.
Wir haben nicht so engen Kontakt.
Ja, okay.
Und Frau Handorf, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ja, klar, wir arbeiten zusammen auf dem Hof, ne?
Ja, haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ja, ja, wir gehen noch zur Schule, die beiden.
Ja, zwei Kinder.
Ja, sind die Kinder gesund?
Ja, ja, sicher, die sind gesund, ja.
Und, was ist Ihr Bomberhof?
Ich verstehe nicht gut.
Ja, wir haben einen Bauernhof.
Ich bin Landwirtin.
Entschuldigung?
Wir haben einen eigenen Bauernhof.
Eigenen Bauern?
Ja, ein Landwirtin.
Landwirtin.
Ja.
Ja, und wir sind fast fertig, Frau Handorf,
aber ich möchte Fragen Ihnen,
ja, haben Sie besuchensregelmäßig Ihre Frauenärztin?
Ja, zum Frauenarzt gehe ich regelmäßig hin, ja.
Ich bin schon ganz früh in der Menopause gewesen, schon mit 45.
Ja, und jetzt war ich vor drei Monaten bei der Gynäkologin
und die hat festgestellt,
dass ich so kleine Milchume in der Gebärmutter habe,
aber sie sagte, so lange die so klein sind,
muss man nichts tun.
Ja, ja, nein, sie sagte, so lange die so klein sind,
Okay, verstehe.
Und Frau Handorf, ich habe keine weitere Fragen.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen, oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, ich will natürlich wissen,
dass wir jetzt gegen, außer diesen Medikament,
das ja zum Glück gut geholfen ist,
das ist ja eine Frage,
und das kann man dagegen tun.
Ja, Frau Handorf, ich denke,
wahrscheinlich haben Sie eine Galan-Blasen-Entzündung,
aber ich würde Sie jetzt körperlich untersuchen,
dann werden Sie dann in der Küche,
in der Küche, in der Küche, in der Küche,
Sie jetzt körperlich untersuchen, dann nehme ich dasuap,
dann werde ich bei Ihnen einmal Labo
und appauerаю untersuchen durcheuvre,
nach den Ergebnisn werde ich mit Ihnen widersprechen.
Ja, okay, gut, das klingt ja nach ein vernünftigen Lah.
Ist mir jemand noch etwas zusätzlich wissen
von Frau Handorf?
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ja, ja.
Ja.
Denken Sie, Sie essen aus 300 Lebensmittel die Milchprodukte enthalten?
Ja, klar.
Ich trinke ja viel Milch und ich esse auch Joghurt und Farbe.
Und Sie bekommen aus 300 Reihandes Sonnenlicht?
Ja, wir sind ja viel draußen bei der Arbeit. Ja, klar.
Vielen Dank.
Können Sie mir sagen, Frau Handorf, ob Sie in Ihrem Berusleben oder Privatleben Stress oder Angst haben?
Ja, Stress haben wir natürlich immer.
Also, ein Bauernhof, da arbeitet man immer so hart an der Existenz.
Und was für uns eben irgendwie ganz traurig ist, die Kinder gehen beide aufs Gymnasium und keiner will den Hof übernehmen.
Ja, und wir wissen also gar nicht, wie es weitergeht, ob wir jetzt dann so das alles auslaufen lassen müssen, wenn wir in Rente gehen.
Und eigentlich ist das so schade. Und ja, das macht mir schon dort die Stress, ja.
Vielen Dank.
Können Sie flach liegen?
Ja, wenn ich mich nicht gerade übergeben muss oder mich krümmen muss vor Bauchschmerzen, kann ich gut flach liegen, ja.
Danke schön.
Ich könnte nicht genau folgen. Wie war Schmerz in Testet?
8 von 10.
Ja, danke.
Deswegen hat er mir auch netterweise ein Schmerzmittel angeboten und das habe ich dann auch akzeptiert und er hat auch vorsichtshalber ein EKG gemacht, ne?
Ja.
Sie sagen gescheiterns weitergehen kann?
Ja, aber ich vergesse ihn so nicht und er arbeitet in Lausikkeit.
Ne, Appetit Lausikkeit habe ich Ihnen eigentlich gesagt.
Ja, okay.
Und in Somni, ja, sie hat ein bisschen Einschlafstörungen, aber überwiegend ist sie halt durch die Nächte einmal zur Toilette gestört, ne?
Schönen guten Abend, Frau Berestin.
Guten Abend, ja, grüße Sie.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen. Hatten Sie Zeit für mich?
Ja, natürlich. Wie haben Sie den gesehen?
Ja, die Patientin heißt Margret Handorf, ist 50 Jahre alt, 1,78 m groß und 63 kg schwer.
3,80 m war richtig.
Ja, okay.
Die Patientin ist heute bei uns, wegen Zeit gestern Abend, 5. Hender, Krampfartiger, Epigastirischer, Schimmersen,
Abdominal Schimmersen und Dorsel G, Schimmersen IV.
Schimmersen ist gerade in der Rechte Schulter aus.
Schimmersen ist nach Abendessen aufgetreten.
Ja, die Patientin erwähnt, dass Schimmersen bei 8 von 10 auf einer Skala regen.
Und bei dem Gespräch habe ich Ihre Vitalparameter kontrollieren.
Im Laufe des Gesprächs haben Sie die Vitalparameter kontrolliert.
Ja, ich habe eine EKG geschrieben.
Und war das auffällig?
Ja, EKG ist unauffällig.
Das ist ja schon mal gut, ja.
Die Patientin habe Febrile Temperatur.
Die Patientin hat Folgender Begleitsymptome.
Sie ist sehr emäßig, 3-4 Mal. Sie sieht nach Schipazereste.
Und Blut erbrochenen.
Sie sieht nach Schipazereste.
Nein, ein Kurse-Seit.
Die Patientin ist dunkel.
Die Patientin ist unaufällig.
Sie sieht regelmäßig Sport.
Die Patientin hat seit 5 bis 6 Jahren Arterielehypertonin.
Und seit 6 Jahren Glupom und Dorsalgi.
Bei der Patientin wurde aus der Kind eine Apendoktomie durchgeführt.
Und die Patientin hatte vor 15 Jahren Arbeitsunfall.
Und Linke hat gelenkt, gebrochen.
Linke hat gelenkt, wurde mit Ost-Eost-Hantees behandelt.
Sie hat regelmäßig Timohexal gegen Glupom 2x gepackt.
Und 95 mg einmal täglich.
Die Patientin ist allergisch. Sie hat viel allergie.
Polinoasis, Hausstab, Birkenpollen, Penicillin und Tetrasiclin allergie.
Sie hat allergie-Krinitis.
Die Patientin ist nicht raucherin.
Sie trinkt ungefähr halbe Flasche Wein täglich.
Und die Rohgun-Konsum wurde verneint.
Ihr Vater ist im Alter von 70 Jahren an Myokartinfarkt verstorben.
Ihre Mutter ist Demenz.
Sie hat Leberkrankheit.
Aber die Patientin hat keinen Kontakt mit ihrem Bruder.
Sie ist verheiratet.
Sie arbeitet als Landwirtin.
Sie hat eine Analyse.
Was machen Sie mit der Patientin?
Um die Verdachtdiagnose bestätigen, würde ich die Patientin als Erstnahmekörperlich untersuchen.
Ich inspeziere den Patienten Bauch.
Ich palpiere.
Was inspezieren Sie noch?
Narben.
Hautverfarbung.
Darauf wollte ich raus.
Bei der Palpation achte ich Schmerz.
Schmerzreaktionen.
Und Reband der Fans.
Und Murphy sein.
Ich höre die Bauch ab.
Darum höre ich Geräusche.
Was machen Sie noch?
Ich habe noch eine andere Analyse.
Was wäre das Verfahren?
Ja, meine Verdachtdiagnose für diese Patientin ist kolesistisch.
Ich kann den Patienten eine ERCP druckführen.
Und sollte sich die Verdachtdiagnose erherten.
Ich empfehle den Patienten Stationale Aufnahme.
Antipyretika, Analgetika.
Antibioseterapie.
Das ist eine Operation.
Was spricht dafür in der Analyse?
Die Patientin.
Ich habe noch eine andere Analyse.
Ich kann sagen, dass die Frau ungefähr 40 Jahre alt ist.
Sie hat Kinder?
Sie ist übergewichtig.
Ich weiß, worauf sie raus wollen.
Sie hat noch ein bisschen darauf hinweist, dass sie nach fettigem Essen los gegangen ist.
Ich gehe gleich über zum Manöverkritik.
Sie haben sich sehr gut geschlagen.
Sie haben mal doppelt gefragt.
Sie haben länger gebraucht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie kritisch die Verdachtdiagnose sind.
Sprachlich fand ich sie sehr so verringen.
Sie haben sich sehr gut verringen.
Sie haben in Schwimmen von Formulieren verringen.
Sie beschreibt Nüktorie.
Sie haben sich sehr gut verringen.
Ich habe mir das als Stichwort aufgeschrieben.
Ich werde Ihnen Blut abnehmen.
Sie haben sich sehr gut geschlagen.
Ich hoffe, dass Sie sich sehr entspannt nach Stuttgart fahren.
Ich wünsche Ihnen allen, dass das noch weitergeht.
Wir sehen uns morgen.
Danke für das Zuhören.
Danke an meinen Doktor, der mir gleich etwas gegen die Scherzen gegeben hat.
Bis demnächst.
Ich wünsche Ihnen einen schönen Abend.